foreign
everyone my name is Dr Miller and the
SCP we're going to be looking at today
is SCP 3663
object class ketter Threat Level Orange
special containment procedures
scp-3663 is currently located in what
were formerly the site-54 maintenance
tunnels to prevent demanifestation no
Personnel are to be given access to the
area and efforts are to be taken to
reduce the tunnel's moisture levels
should
scp-3663d manifest mobile Task Force new
4 box cutters are to be mobilized with
the goal of a locating
scp-3663 and B preventing any damage
occurring to The Entity if possible
scp-3663 is to be fitted with GPS
tracking devices to Aid in recontainment
once located
scp-3663 is to be transferred to a
mobile pipe network and remanded to
site-54
efforts are to be undertaken to
discourage
scp-3663 from transporting itself to a
location within two kilometers of scp-15
description
scp-3663 is a humanoid entity
constructed primarily from cardboard in
the form of boxes and tubes adhesive
tape and Twine
scp-3663 is fully capable of movement
and vocalization Via an unknown
mechanism and has proven to be
semi-sapient responding to questions and
reacting to its immediate environment
the interior of
scp-3663 contains crude cardboard and
paper models of all major human organs
with colored wool representing blood
vessels and the nervous system
scp-3663 does not require these
components to function and their purpose
within the entity is unknown
scp-3663 is capable of instantaneously
transporting both itself and other
objects over long distances with no
upper limit to the entity's range
observed the method by which this is
achieved is currently unknown though it
is known that physical contact with the
entity is required despite being able to
utilize its abilities regardless of
physical location
scp-3663 has shown extreme preference
for 3663 applicable regions defined as
an enclosed tunnel-like space or network
of spaces measuring at least 40
centimeters in diameter has been
stricken from the document and will
invariably choose to manifest within
such areas
scp-3663 behavior is easily predictable
when not influenced by outside forces
the entity will engage in a simple
cyclic pattern of actions which have
been recorded as follows
number one
scp-3663 manifests in a 3663 applicable
area emitting low vocalizations and
waving its arms in a manner suggesting
attempted intimidation or fright The
Entity will begin roaming the area
pausing periodically to emit louder
higher pitched noises
number two
scp-3663 will attempt to make its way
towards any human subject in the area
note that if no subject is nearby this
action will not commence and
scp-3663 will simply remain in the area
indefinitely
rarely
scp-3663 has been observed pursuing
subjects outside of
scp-3663 applicable areas to a distance
of at most 50 meters
number three the subject is gripped by
The Entity and experienced heightened
apprehension and or paranoia
scp-3663 demanifests
number four
scp-3663 manifests in a second 3663
applicable location along with the
subject who is invariably unconscious
but otherwise unharmed after releasing
the subject and moving a short distance
scp-3663 D manifests a second time
reappearing in a third location and
triggering the beginning of a new cycle
if at any point during this cycle
scp-3663 is damaged in such a way as to
inhibit movement or is moved more than
50 meters away from an scp-3663
applicable area it will instantaneously
demanifest returning to the beginning of
a new cycle in a reparent state small
changes such as minor Cuts or tears will
not trigger this effect
addendum one interview log 3663 1.
interviewed
scp-3663 interviewer researcher Doyle
forward the following interview is
conducted by a two-way audio visual
recording systems embedded within a
makeshift interview chamber located in
sign
scp-3663 Central containment area
formerly the site-54 maintenance tunnels
begin log
hello
scp-3663 I was wondering if
it's a double monster I'm sorry I'm the
tunnel monster
not
scp-3663 the tunnel monster that's me I
I see so uh tunnel monster
why do you do what you do moving people
around I mean the tunnel monster
captures people
that's me I'm the tall monster I capture
people and I take them into the tunnels
where I live
in the tunnels the pipes
I'm the tunnel monster I understand that
but what do you hope to achieve by doing
it
you seem to pick your locations at
random so it seems to me that you're not
really making much of a difference you
could just as easily please stop
that's what I do I have to do it I'm not
I am
the tunnel monster
it's me
please stop what
we're trying to help you here you can't
want to spend all your time on the
ground
we can get you set up here with your own
room he wouldn't even have to crawl
about in those dirty pipes anymore
doesn't that sound nice
what do you say please I'm I'm
scp-3663 pauses for approximately five
seconds
the tunnel monster
I don't want to
to do this
it's what I do
I have to do it
I'm the tunnel monster
I I do it on the tunnel thing the tunnel
monster two wet patches are observed
forming on
scp-3663's face
in the pipes
hiding in the towels going to get you I
have to do it
but please
scp-3663 front surface begins to lose
structural Integrity due to accumulated
water damage please
I don't want to play anymore I'm the
monster
the tunnels
that will be all for today thank you
end lock
due to the possibility of severely
damaging
scp-3663 to the point of initiating a
new cycle and a breach of containment no
further interviews are being scheduled
for the foreseeable future
addendum 2 event 3663 Delta
on 20
scp-3663's Behavior diverged briefly
from established patterns at 1420 The
Entity emerged from the site-54
maintenance tunnels and began to emit
vocalizations in excess of 80 decibels
these vocalizations described as pained
by on-site staff had a profound
psychological effect placing many
personnel into a State of Shock phrases
recorded include don't leave me I don't
want this and let me go home among
others for approximately four hours
scp-3663 wandered the facility attacking
staff and engaging in small-scale
vandalism of facilities of node is the
fact that
scp-3663 repeatedly attempted self-harm
by means of knives pipes water taps and
Firearms while
scp-3663 was repeatedly destroyed in
this process it subsequently
re-manifested in the nearest air duct or
maintenance area
following the event two bodies of former
Personnel were recovered from within
site-54 autopsies showed that cause of
death was a buildup of paper residue or
wood pulp in all major blood vessels as
well as sinuses ear tubes and the
majority of the digestive and
respiratory systems a number of other
staff members were found to have been
affected to a lesser degree but are
expected to make full recoveries the
entity's object class and definition of
an scp-3663 applicable area have been
updated accordingly
subsequent information gathering
revealed that this event coincided
almost exactly with the death of Person
of Interest
3663-1 see addendum 3 for more details
who died of natural causes at the age of
79. prior to their death the individual
in question had led an entirely
unremarkable life with no connection to
any anomalous groups individuals or
objects attempts to establish a
connection with the creation or origin
of
scp-3663 are currently ongoing
addendum three Discovery lock
video transcript 3663 1.
forward the following is a transcript of
video 3663 1 recovered from civilian
CCTV footage in the footage displays the
first recorded evidence of
scp-3663's existence prior to this date
no records sightings or physical
disturbances suggesting anomalous
activity relating to the entity have
been found
begin transcript
1522-0809 1979.
midnight two young children both males
between the ages of 8 and 12 are seen
playing in an abandoned construction
yard one designated Person of Interest
3663 one is running from the other
designated Person of Interest
3663-2 Who is wearing a crude cardboard
suit resembling scp-3663
0-23 both individuals leave the camera's
view briefly before returning the game
they are playing seems to revolve around
two chasing one through an unfinished
water drainage system POI 3663 II
repeatedly grabs one and attempts to
pull them deeper into the tunnel
likewise POI 36631 uses a number of
Make-Believe weapons to fend off the
assaults
a 104 the sky is observed darkening
slightly as POI 3663-1 trips on a length
of pipe POI 3663 II is seen speaking
grabbing one and pulling them upright
POI 3663-1 pushes them away apparently
angered POI 3663-2 steps backward as if
struck
a 130 POI
3663-2 begins to shudder while the
visible Sky continues to darken note
that no anomalous weather patterns were
recorded during the period of time in
question POI 3663-1 clutches at their
head pointing at POI
3663-2 and shouting both children appear
extremely distressed
o-150 POI 3663 two tries and fails to
remove the upper portion of their suit
o249 camera visuals are lost replaced by
Static a continuous hum is hurt all
other electronic devices in a 200 meter
radius are also recorded to a failed
simultaneously
o412 camera visuals return neither
individual is in View and no additional
anomalies are observed
0.608
scp-3663 is seen walking past the camera
The Entity shutters briefly clawing at
its face before demanifesting
and transcript
POI 3663-1 was later found lying
unconscious in a disused subway line
over 4 000 kilometers away they
displayed no memory of either
scp-3663 or Person of Interest
3663-2 and claimed to have been playing
alone societal reintegration of the
subject occurred with no complications
to date neither Person of Interest 3663
2 nor any record of their continued
existence have been recovered
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
Dr felryn
silent
tomothy
zargaron
Professor Puffer
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J tilp
well-remmer
vinyl
gavios the hollow
zazapan
lamke
Dr Briggs
tailored printers
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
oh crap guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
and NJ vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you